all right let's get into patriot mail
for the week continuing with our new
very very timely patriot mail
introductions so what if the president's
been accused of sexual harassment
fifteen times or that he paid hush money
to a porn star
at least he never wore a tan suit
Patriot Man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because
freedom
alright this week's hatred mail contains
one of the primary calling cards of the
hatred but it's only going to be
observable to people who were watching
and can read the transcript along with
us because if you're only listening you
won't be able to pick up the calling
card in this one let's take a listen and
then I'll tell you what it is you're a
[ __ ] Dave in uneducated ideologically
possessed fool who has no place
spreading lies about those you disagree
worth there is nothing wrong with being
proud your whites please like Africa
have some of the lowest IQ averages in
the world coming from a globalist like
Pakman I wonder what the facts really
are Pakman does that mouth of yours
unhinge Jesus that thing is big yes
someone noticing that sometimes when I
am amplifying and crescendoing that my
mouth tends to open fully yeah and
that's okay so if you couldn't tell
there are two and if you were listening
you wouldn't know there are two
instances here of the word your which
should be you apostrophe re but the
hatred in both cases has written it why
oh you are which is really the calling
card of hate reott ism it's especially
bad when he's calling you a [ __ ] you
got to get the right more right in that
case I'm if you're saying you're a [ __ ]
you gotta get why oh you apostrophe re
and by the way globalist I'm glad that
this actually came up because globalist
now is the subject of much discussion in
the public sphere as well also included
in hatred male globalist is often a
discrete way of saying Jew right even
though it's less and less discrete the
more they try to use it Jew and
globalist are being used interchangeable
by many conspiracy theorists and rest
assured that you can give a big middle
finger to the hey tree it's because
we've got a coupon code hey tree at 40
if you use the coupon code hey tree at
40 you get a 40% discount off of the
membership of your choice it could be
the monthly it could be the yearly hey
tree at 40 we'll save you 40% off of
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership very exciting